you weren't what
metal foundry
oh thank you man I appreciate that you
scared me too much for me to make fun of
you that much more
these guys are more my speed you know
what I mean nice wholesome looking white
guy salt of the earth you know what I
mean privately voted for Trump privately
oh you got a whole thigh tattoo what is
that why you got a gorilla on your thigh
bro that's the stupidest tattoo I ever
seen in my life you imagine I
got a Santa Claus on my forehead that's
what your is right there
she said try sucking his dick and look
at it
you're a real one most girls use that as
an excuse not to
as if something couldn't get more
disgusting you did it you don't need
more obstacles let me tell you he's a
married man you don't need more
obstacles to oral sex all right make it
as inviting as possible put some corkies
on it
[Laughter]